How are the slopes of two parallel lines related?
Take these two parallel lines for example.
If the slope of this line is M1
and that of this one is M2,
then how are M1 and M2 related?
You don't really have to think here.
It's obvious.
The tilt or the inclination is the same.
M1 will be equal to M2.
The slopes of parallel lines are the same.
Okay, great!
So how are the slopes of two lines
that are perpendicular to each other related?
Take these two lines for instance.
Assume their slopes are 'M3 'and 'M4'.
This may not be obvious,
but the product of their slopes is 'minus 1'.
'M3' times 'M4' is equal to 'minus 1'.
Another fancy way to say it
would be that they are negative reciprocals of each other.
'M3' will equal 'minus 1' over 'M4'.
And 'M4' will equal 'minus 1' over 'M3'.
If lines are parallel, their slopes are equal.
And if they are perpendicular,
then the product of their slopes is 'minus 1'.
In this example, we are given the coordinates of A and B
and have been asked to find the equation of the
perpendicular bisector of 'AB'.
Pause the video and try finding the equation.
First, let's plot the two points on the coordinate plane.
'3' comma 'minus 1' will be here.
And '1' comma '3' will be this point.
Let's join points A and B.
It's perpendicular bisector will look a bit like this.
Let's call it 'CD'.
'CD' is perpendicular to 'AB' and it will also bisect 'AB'.
Now we've been asked to find the equation of this blue line,
the equation of line 'CD'.
With the slope intercept form,
let's assume that it's equation is 'Y is equal to MX plus B'.
How do we find the equation?
We need 'M' and 'B'.
'M' is the slope of 'CD'.
And 'B' is its 'Y' intercept.
How can we find the slope of 'CD'?
To find the slope of any line,
we need the coordinates of at least two of its points.
We have the coordinates of A and B.
Which can give us the slope of 'AB'.
And as 'AB' and 'CD' are perpendicular,
the slope of 'AB' will give us the slope of 'CD'.
Their product will equal 'minus one'.
So we will have 'M'.
Now how do we find 'B', which is the 'Y' intercept?
Look at the slope-intercept form.
If we have 'M',
then we just need the coordinates of one point on CD to find B.
Because then,
we can substitute the coordinates in place of 'X' and 'Y' and get 'B'.
The only point at which we can find the coordinates is this one.
The intersection of 'AB' and 'CD'.
Because it is also a midpoint of 'AB'.
And we can easily find the midpoint of 'AB'
as we have the coordinates of its endpoints.
So after we get the slope of 'CD',
we find the midpoint of 'AB',
which will also give us 'B'.
Once we have 'M' and 'B',
we can easily find the equation of 'CD'.
Okay, so what is the slope of 'AB'?
It will be 'minus 1', 'minus 3', over '3 minus 1'.
Difference of Y coordinates over the difference of X coordinates.
This gives us 'minus 2'.
The slope of 'AB' is 'minus 2'.
Now we find the slope of 'CD'.
As 'AB' and 'CD' are perpendicular,
the product of the slopes will be 'minus 1'.
So 'minus 2' times 'M' will equal 'minus 1'.
Slope of 'AB' times the slope of 'CD' equals 'minus 1'.
We get the slope of 'CD' as 1 over 2.
Now we get to the midpoint of AB.
The X coordinate of the midpoint
is the average of the X coordinates of the endpoints.
The X coordinate will be 3 plus 1 over 2.
And the Y coordinate of the midpoint,
will be 'minus 1 plus 3 over 2'.
2 comma 1 will be the midpoint of 'AB'.
And it is also one of the points on 'CD'.
So we can substitute these values in place of X and Y.
Substituting the values of M, X and Y here,
we get 'one equals half times two plus B'.
Solving this we get the value of  'B as zero'.
'M is half' and 'B is zero'.
The equation of line 'CD' will be 'Y is equal to X over 2'.
This video, was a bit taxing I'm sure.
If you haven't understood it well,
make sure you go through it again.
I am sure, it will make more sense.